[Music]
Ro
lithium is at the center of the energy
transition crucial to the production of
batteries for electric cars in this film
we'll take you on a journey from Chile
to England to Norway to explore two
massive questions hanging over this
industry and everyone who invests in it
can it increase production enough to
meet surging Global demand and can it do
so while minimizing negative social and
environmental impacts Chile has the
world's largest reserves of lithium the
bulk of its production is done by the
Santiago listed company sqm and by far
its biggest mine is here at the salad de
atakama a giant Salt Flat in the middle
of Chile's atakama desert the driest
place in the world outside
Antarctica this Salt Flat formed over
hundreds of thousands of years as
rainwater flow down from the nearby
mountains collecting minerals including
lithium along the way under its surface
is brine extremely salty water with a
small but valuable lithium
content the braine is put into the first
of a series of pools where the water
begins to evaporate away as it passes
through each pool the braine becomes
more concentrated therefore with a
higher proportion of lithium as more
water evaporates and other minerals are
removed at the last of the pools here at
the cellar the lithium content reaches
nearly
5% the brine is then loaded into trucks
that take it to sqm's processing plant
outside the coastal city of
antofagasta 200 km to the
Southwest there it is turned into sacks
of lithium carbonate and lithium
hydroxide which are then shipped to
manufacturers mainly in Asia for use in
battery production this plant accounts
for nearly a fifth of the world's
lithium processing capacity
[Music]
but while the lithium sector has put
Chile at the center of one of the
world's highest growth in Industries
some people in the region surrounding
the salad atakama such as entrepreneur
Rosa Ramos are worried that brine
extraction by lithium companies could be
depleting their water
resources
sqm says that it has been careful to
minimize the environmental impacts of
its activities and that studies carried
out by its own experts and by outside
academics show no grounds for concern
about negative effects on local communi
Water
Resources but the company acknowledges
that while it has been investing in
studies on this question and providing
data to outside researchers there is a
shortage of truly dependent information
and for scientists like Mariana cetto
who has worked extensively on the salad
deama and who we met up with in Chile's
capital of Santiago without that
independent data from the government or
from other parties unaffiliated with the
mining industry it will be impossible to
put this matter to rest it's quite
difficult to have like objective
information to to understand if there's
been there is an impact or not for
example in Sal salad dama the models for
me are quite convincing but I still have
my small doubts and to able to be to
solve these doubts I don't have the
information so I just have to trust
their models and understand that they
are coherent and in that from that point
of view in Salama particularly the
models and the information they show
would show that there isn't an impact
from the brain extraction not even in
the lagoons and not even on the on the
freshwater uh
availability
for investors in financial hubs like
London who are pumping billions into the
supply chain for lithium and other
critical minerals concerns about
sustainable production are high on the
agenda this sector offers huge potential
rewards but at a time when investment
managers are under massive scrutiny over
their environmental social and
governance credentials it comes with big
big risks too Brian mennel is the
founder of techmet an investment company
that has acquired stakes in several
businesses involved in the extraction
and processing of lithium as well as
other minerals crucial to the energy
transition mining Parts nature is not
sustainable it's a you're exploiting a
finite resource and nothing that
develops a natural source is without
some
environmental impact and carbon
footprint
um however you know I think it's it's
wrong to see the mining industry or the
lithium production industry in
particular as one that can't be well
governed and transparent and low
environmental impact and low carbon
footprint and a lot of that what we're
doing as techm is to ensure that all of
our projects meet very high standards
menel says that the energy transition
and the surging demand it is bringing
for metals like lithium presents a once
in a century investment opportunity
Tesla are to reach their target of
producing 20 million electric vehicles a
year by 2030 that alone would require
almost seven times the present total
Global annual supply of lithium and
that's before GM or Ford or VW or the
Chinese who will continue to produce 2/3
of the world's batteries and 2third of
the world's electric vehicles and are
growing quicker than us and have a
15year head start in managing the supply
chain you know there's no model or no
scenario where these Metals do not have
to go up in price much much further and
stay up in price much much longer and as
countries around the world begin to
worry about obtaining sufficient
supplies of these Metals menal says far
more investment will be needed to ensure
energy Security in particular he says
China has an unhealthily large market
share in the production of lithium ion
batteries and in the refining of lithium
chemicals for them China's been building
critical minerals processing capacity
over the last 15 20 years while the rest
of the world was sleeping and and as a
result of that they have economies of
scale that make them competitive to a
point which creates massive challenges
for the rest of the world to balance or
or reduce that's the one factor the
other factor is the fact that the
Chinese state in the pursuit of this
long-term strategic objective of
dominating the inputs into the energy
transition have been prepared to
subsidize the low margin elements of the
supply chain in order to control the
supply chain major economies throughout
the world have been scrambling to drive
greater investment into lithium
production in the US Joe Biden's recent
inflation reduction act has provided
powerful Financial incentives for new
projects in this space the European
commission has followed up with a
proposed new law of its own to drive
production and processing capacity for
lithium and other critical minerals so
to give us more time to prepare I'm
announcing today that we're going to
ease the transition to electric vehicles
and while the UK government has recently
cut back several major clean energy
policies it says it is committed to
increasing the country's domestic
production of lithium to get a sense of
its chances of doing so we headed down
to the coastal County of Cornwall in
Southwest
England Cornwall has a mining history
dating back to the Bronze Age but the
sector has been a shadow of its former
self since the late 19th
century now some in the county are
daring to hope for a mining Revival
driven by two startups that are working
to extract lithium from beneath the
Cornish soil one of them is British
lithium run by Australian father and Sun
team Rodrick and Andrew Smith Australia
is currently the world's biggest
producer of lithium accounting for more
than 40% of global extraction in
2022 but rodick Smith a veteran of the
Australian mining sector says that
Europe including the UK is a more
attractive investment proposition
I explored four discovered and built a
number of mines in Western Australia uh
four or five of them and Australia is
good to me it's got a booming mining
industry and of course the lithium
industry is booming there now too but I
think one thing that's missing Australia
is not very good at adding value to
Natural Resources it's a it's a quarry
of the world but they have no car
industry for example they don't make a
single car in Australia so they're not
going to have a car battery plant and
the lithium mines that are being built
there it's not going into batteries it's
all going to China where they make
batteries and make cars in contrast
argue The Smiths their operation in
Cornwall will be well placed to serve
manufacturers in their region including
a new battery Factory to be built by
India's tartar Motors in Somerset 100
miles to the Northeast the lithium that
occurs in Corall is unique in the world
so we ended up building a pilot plant
behind us which was completed in 2021
and it uses a physical separation
methodology to remove the lithium mic
out of the rock for physical separation
make a concentrate we then heat that up
dissolve it in pure water change the ph
and refine it into the final battery
grade lii carbonate we received
Government funding to for R&D and for
building toward building this pilot
plant and one of the requirements of the
government funding was that we have a
independent
Benchmark comparing our process and our
actual development against existing
industry and the carbon emissions are
less than half the best current
producing hardw mine and the water
consumption is is is way ahead of you
know certainly looking at the brine
people so it does stack up extremely
[Music]
well as the demand for lithium surges
and producers like the Smith's race to
increase Supply trading venues like the
London Metal Exchange could play an
important role in keeping this Market
running
smoothly the lme traces its history to
1571 and is one of the few exchanges in
the world still to rely on the open
outcry system of trading between
individuals on its floor in the city of
London probably over the next uh 10
years most Market commentators expect
the the the the lithium Market in size
to perhaps quadruple currently however
almost no lithium trading is done on
open markets like the lme most sales are
made through long-term agreements
between producers and customers either
battery makers or increasingly car
makers themselves pricing isn't
particularly uh transparent producers
and consumers typically uh enter into
bilateral negotiations and use fixed
prices that are set by The Producers
which is quite different to what you see
uh in more mature markets like copper or
aluminium where the industry typically
references um index prices I think it's
fair to say there is a huge amount of
uncertainty around how and de demand and
Supply will come into balance uh in
future and you can see that um in the
price volatility uh in recent years
which has been very very high maybe just
to put it into perspective uh at the
beginning of this year the the lithium
hydroxide price was around
$85,000 um dollars per ton right now
it's trading at closer to 28,000 so in
less than a year the prices come off by
2/3 um but in Prior years has as much as
quadrupled in a single year Martin
argues that the shift to index-based
pricing will help car makers and Battery
producers to better manage these price
fluctuations and give them greater
flexibility and security of Supply the
lme is also looking to address concerns
about sustainability by introducing a
passport system that guarantees minimum
standards of Social and environmental
responsibility more than half of lme
Brands um are starting to publish this
information and this can then be looked
at by Downstream uh consumer consumers
to really have confidence that the you
the green EV that they're driving
actually has a low production carbon
footprint so the energy transition is
undoubtedly going to have a a very large
impact on the global Metals market and
by consequence on the on the LM as well
um perhaps the biggest impact since the
the rise of China um in the early 2000s
which had a a huge impact on on metal
demand
Chile's huge reserves of lithium have
given this country a chance to play a
central role in the global energy
transition and the government here in
Santiago now needs to make sure that
this delivers real economic benefits for
the country as a
whole in April 2023 the government of
president Gabrielle borich a
left-leaning
37-year-old announced a new lithium
strategy that would bring major changes
for the
industry most notably all new lithium
projects would need to be carried out
through a partnership between private
sector businesses and a state-owned
mining company a move that was
criticized by some as a form of
nationalization
the new plan is a big deal for s qm
whose current lease for lithium
extraction expires in
2030 today we are estimating that the
demand of lithium is around 930,000 ton
this will be the demand of this year
which is H 20% higher than last year and
we are estimating that by 2030 the
demand of lithium could reach 3 million
tons it's some optimistic scenarios we
even have up to 3.4 3.5 million tons so
a lot of lithium is needed in the future
that means that we will need Supply from
every possible origin Chile definitely
will have to be one of of the future
Supply countries okay so that means that
we need to grow and the policy that the
Chilean government has announced in a
way I see it as a a to put some some uh
let's say clear rules of the game for
future Supply uh from Chile the
government strategy would also encourage
new lithium operations to use new forms
of technology such as direct lithium
extraction which would remove lithium
from brine at the site of extraction and
then re-inject the processed liquid back
into the brine
body
nothing has been 100%
proven so you need to be 100% sure that
things will work before engaging uh
fully in adopting these new technologies
and that's why I see it more as a
compliment in the first
years but that means that brain process
which is already today very sustainable
could become even more sustainable in
the future it's not um as easy as you
know we'll will'll pump here and re
inject here it has to be we have to
think where to inject at what depth will
it will it compensate the pumping it's h
from a hydrological point of view it's
not it's not
simple it's not clear whether B's
government will be able to get its new
plan through Parliament but it reflects
a wider Race by countries around the
world to benefit economically from the
demand for critical
minerals some members of Chile's
indigenous population say that the new
strategy May not address their concerns
about the impacts of lithium
mining Ariel Leon a lawyer from Chile's
North has been helping a community in
Chile's marunga region in the southern
part of the atakama to win legal rulings
against lithium extraction near that
land
IND
in the region of the salad de atakama
sqm has put some of its lithium profits
towards local community projects like
this new hotel which will be owned and
run by the local community of
toono but Community leaders here say
they still want to see more effort from
the government and mining companies to
engage in
consultation
and some argue that Shoppers worldwide
need to start thinking about how to
reduce their consumption of resources as
well as their carbon
emissions
for
[Music]
underground deposits are not the only
source of lithium the more the electric
vehicle Market grows so in due course
does the supply of used car batteries
like the ones behind me which can be
crushed and separated into their
constituent
elements this facility in Southern North
way is the biggest battery recycling
plant in Europe it's the main operation
of hedr volt a joint venture between
Swedish battery maker northvolt and
Norwegian aluminium producer nor
hedro for several years thanks to strong
government incentives most new cars sold
in Norway have been electric something
that has now started to yield a growing
supply of used batteries we are located
in Norway because this is the most
mature market for uh EV cars in Europe
and we are ensuring that all these
batteries are reycled so that the
materials inside them can be
reintroduced into a circular value chain
and become new batteries again and again
and again we can recover with today's
technology up to
95% of the critical raw materials this
will be an extremely important source of
uh of materials to enable further
electrification we are actually creating
an above ground mine we are an
alternative to traditional Mining and
that enables also a closed loop in the
local markets because we can establish
where these batteries end their life and
ensure that we have additional
production of critical raw materials in
that market so this will enable Europe
to have its own mine in a way because we
create an above ground mine uh in the
Home Market where we produce critical uh
raw materials to supply to to supply the
the cell manufacturers with what they
need to build new batteries the obvious
reason uh to be excited about this
industry is is the sales of EV cars and
you know we have very good statistics
for that and then you have some
uncertainty related to the to the
lifetime of the batteries but but uh
these batteries will need to be recycled
sooner or later uh so uh it's it's quite
obvious that the market will come and
then uh the question is who who will uh
uh become the winners in this
market as for who will be the biggest
winners and perhaps the losers too in
the global lithium Revolution that
contest is now well underway and now
we're on this fourth Industrial
Revolution which is electrification and
decarbonization and it's primarily going
to be fueled by lithium in its use of
battery storage it's going to unlock
Renewables is going to enable us to
decarbonize our transport link so it's
key to to the future of mankind I think
if any material is a candidate to be the
oil of the 21st and 22nd century it's
lithium lithium is overwhelmingly
dominant in that electrochemical Arena
and that electrochemical storage arena
is going to be one of the cornerstones
of the global industrial and
technological landscape for the next 100
years not
fore
the transition to cleaner forms of
energy is forcing businesses and
investors to rethink their work from
first principles and that is presenting
a chance to build a new economic model
that is not only lower in carbon
emissions but truly better and fairer
for communities and ecosystems all over
the world the booming lithium industry
is at the center of that struggle
companies investors and governments in
this space have some of the most
exciting opportunities in the 21st
century economy but those opportunities
come with intense scrutiny heavy
responsibility and some intimidating
challenges this was the third film in a
three-part series please make sure to
like comment and subscribe for future ft
films